this is the airship Hindenburg burning
up while trying to land in New Jersey in
1937 it's 97 people were trapped inside
it was a big deal at the time
the Hindenburg was the greatest
passenger airship ever built imagine
something the size of an ocean liner but
in the air and it could make the journey
from Europe to the u.s. in half the time
it was a shining example of the future
of commercial air travel and all it took
was a spark to bring the whole thing
down
[Music]
air travel was on everyone's minds in
the early 20th century aviators like
Charles Lindbergh and Amelia Earhart
became huge celebrities after they
conquered the Atlantic and airplanes but
airships were something else entirely
just two years after Lindbergh famously
crossed the Atlantic in a cramped
monoplane a giant German Zeppelin flew
around the world carrying paid
passengers who ate comfortably in a
full-service dining room and slept in
private berths and in 1936 the biggest
and grandest airship yet was built the
German lz-129 named the Hindenburg there
she is the fine example of simplicity
and economy of design a triumph of light
of an aircraft like of which the world
has never seen before it was a monstrous
feat of engineering and a symbol of
Germany's rising prominence in the early
years of the Nazi Party the world's
greatest light of an airship the
Hindenburg that Superliner of the sky
made her first trip to America from
Germany and March 1936 that year the
Hindenburg made 17 intercontinental
round trips carrying passengers it had a
dining room too and a reading room and a
separate lounge it even had a smoking
room a separately ventilated space where
passengers could smoke under the
supervision of the maitre d who held the
only lighter which brings us to a very
important element in this story hydrogen
hydrogen gas is lighter than air and
people that used it for centuries to
lift aircraft like hot-air balloons it's
highly flammable but cheap and easy to
make as opposed to it's safer non
flammable cousin helium but the United
States who at this time produced the
rare gas almost exclusively embargoed
its sale in 1925 countries around the
world developing lighter than air
programs had to rely on hydrogen and
their airships were blowing up in the US
the hydrogen powered roma exploded and
killed 34 in 1922 in 19
23 the French Navy airship Deak smooth
did 252 dead and in 1930 the UK ship
r101 went down 48 dead but the Germans
weren't worried by the time the
Hindenburg embarked on its first North
American flight of 1937 not a single
German passenger airship had crashed on
may 6 1937 that's not what they did
the ship was 12 hours late and what's
worse the crew had good reason to
believe it was leaking hydrogen the back
end was dipping toward the ground and
they couldn't properly balance the ship
dumping more water ballast than ever
before in vain efforts to level off plus
the air was charged with electrostatic
activity due to a recent thunderstorm
and another one was on the way that
means they were trying to quickly land
an enormous hydrogen-filled airship in
electrically charged conditions that was
likely leaking flammable gas and well
[Music]
when human burg caught fire a crew of
reporters gathered for a routine photo
op sprung into action
photojournalist Sam Scheer only had time
for a single exposure but of all the
press photos taken that day it's this
one that's most remembered it somehow
manages to perfectly frame the entire
disaster the panicked crowd running in
view of newsreel cameras with the
hastily dumped water ballasts still
visible in the background the name
Hindenburg barely illuminated by the
bright flames lighting up the entire top
of the ship and the faulty tail now
completely engulfed just moments before
the flames burst out of the nose and
brought the ship crashing to the ground
the image of the Hindenburg burning was
unlike anything people had seen before a
disaster photographed as it was taking
place in the end out of 97 people on
board 35 plus one crewmen on the ground
died that means that about two-thirds of
the people inside of that actually
escaped but the numbers didn't matter
hydrogen airships never flew paid
passengers again after that day the
Hindenburg wasn't the first or even the
deadliest passenger airship disaster it
was just the one that was caught on film
and that's why it was the last
the last doctor webisode was about
Scott's doomed expedition to the South
Pole but there were some photos that we
didn't include and one in particular
that I really want to show you and
they're in this book so that's gonna
appear next week in video lab our
YouTube membership program just go to
box.com /join to learn more and as
always thanks for watching I'm looking
at you insane the entire time